Mr benét dziak you've covered the best
and worst performances of a dozen actors
on top five yet no actresses why is this
that's not true I did two episodes on
Jennifer Lawrence why'd you guys call me
in here like this
please of all the actresses you could
have picked from you chose Jennifer
Lawrence that's not my fault they voted
for her in my Twitter poll
it's 2018 Walter the Ghostbusters Star
Wars and oceans franchises all feature
female leads now oh my god how good was
oceans eight right you want to defeat
Dinah Rob and some trolls while you're
at it it's time to cover some leading
ladies Walter what actress would you do
a countdown on if you could
[Music]
these are the top 5 best Sandra Bullock
performances number 5 while you were
sleeping there's few things more
nostalgic for me then Christmas time in
Chicago Sandra Bullock plays Lucy a
train station attendant who saves a
passenger's life when he's pushed onto
the El tracks after a white light turns
into a convoluted conundrum
Lucy is accidentally engaged to the
unconscious man and a part of a zany but
lovable family throughout the movie
Bullock gives little quirks to Lucy that
make her silly and relatable what ok
some more relatable than others but it's
easy to see why she falls for this
family and why they easily accept her
back speaking of falling in love lucy
spend some time with her unconscious
husband's brother Jack I'm sorry your
fiance Bullock and Pullman's on-screen
chemistry was electric and engaging you
have to watch to fully appreciate but
every shot of them makes you want to
Yelp just kiss already
there's so many fun moments in the story
but Bullock's performance is what makes
this film were three watching over and
over her portrayal could have very
easily leaned on the rom-com cheese
factor to the points of an audience but
she made Lucy charming and sweet she
blends humor with sadness to produce
such a natural quality that it's hard
not to fall in love with her yourself
number 4
speed in 1994 Bullock raced onto screens
alongside Keanu Reeves in the movie
speed speed tells the harrowing story of
a bus rigged to explode if it goes under
50 miles per hour Sandra Bullock plays
the character Annie a woman who ends up
driving the bus while Reeves character
LAPD officer Jack Travon attempts to
thwart the Bob Bullock creates a complex
character determined to survive through
an impossibly dangerous situation she
plays her with humor and grace if the
bus blows up he wins what if you win
then tomorrow we'll play another one but
I'm not available to drive tomorrow busy
but she still has moments of panic that
any person thrown into this situation
would have she stays cool under pressure
but she still keeps the performance
grounded stay on her get off
[Music]
her chemistry with Keanu Reeves is also
undeniable they find time in this
life-or-death scenario to playfully
flirt and build a relationship as you
know relationships that start under
intense circumstances they never last
yeah speed is a fun edge-of-your-seat
action movie with some great
performances by Bullock and Reeves
definitely worth a watch number three
Miss Congeniality Bullock one audience
is over with her performance as agent
Gracie Hart in the commuting
fish-out-of-water movie Miss
Congeniality released in 2000 the movie
follows Gracie as she is forced to go
undercover as a contestant in the Miss
United States beauty pageant it is not a
beauty pageant
it is a scholarship program great sorry
the problem is agent Hart would never be
defined as elegant or graceful she has
mere days to transform into a beauty
queen with the help of a coach played by
Michael Caine hijinks ensue Bullock's
performance is funny engaging sarcastic
and yet has moments of true genuine
emotion
and
I really do want world peace she created
some very memorable scenes
I remember reciting these lines with
friends in high school and of course
singing just you it's not a
revolutionary or groundbreaking comedy
but it's a fun ride and Bullock's
performance will bring you a smile your
blade never break it wait I'm sorry
what's happening
you said coach my back okay so here I am
now look at it loose and I never switch
ice never Blake now look at the camera
the cameras or lever back left at a
camera my work here is done
and boy number two the Blind Side in
2010 Sandra Bullock won an Academy Award
for her performance as LeAnn tewi in The
Blind Side the movie is a semi
biographical account of the life of
football star Michael Oher Michael is a
troubled team from a rough area that
becomes enrolled in a Christian private
school at the beginning of the movie
there he struggles academically and with
fitting in he's eventually taken in by
the TUI family who adopts him helps him
get his grades up and signs him up for
football he then becomes a star player
and is scouted by many colleges and
eventually plays for the NFL Bullock
plays the matriarch of the family it
would've been very easy for any actress
to simply play this role at face value
as a typical southern kind of pushy
suburban mom what really elevates the
performance is the many subtleties that
she adds she is commanding and Stern yet
caring her mannerisms show how guarded
the character has to be to keep her busy
life afloat before Michael enters it the
character feels so real and grounded
there are small wonderful moments
throughout the movie where Bullock uses
just the slightest twitch or inflection
to show the real emotion the character
feels but doesn't allow herself to show
many have debated the value and messages
of the movie itself but has worth a
watch for this wonderfully subtle and
engaging performance and the number one
set standard
performance is gravity this gorgeous
film showcase Sandra Bullock as a
powerhouse of talent American astronaut
Ryan stone and her crew becomes stranded
in space from a floating debris field
after becoming cut off from the only
other life around she must find her way
to safety before the debris orbits back
around obliterating her chances of
returning to Earth she carries the film
at times with not much more than her
face the other humans don't exactly
stick around for the rest of the film so
a lot of her job was to sustain the
story alone in order to simulate the
weightlessness of space
Bullock spent 10 hour days in a harness
rigged with robotic arms to make her
choreographed movements perfectly sync
with the camera since it was a hassle to
get in and out of she usually just
stayed in it during breaks it was
nothing like the visual feast we got to
see from the final product nothing to
look at but lights and periodic machine
parts of the giant box built to house
the actors and equipment all the crew
worked outside of it giving instructions
through an earpiece as isolating as that
sounds
Bullock made the frustration work for
her in an interview she compared her
struggles to that of her characters
there's no one around you're frustrated
nothing works
you're in pain you're lonely you want
someone to fix everything for you but
they can't all of those things I was
feeling and yet Bullock makes this
impossible task themed effortless from
elation to helpless grief she ran the
gamut of emotions in this intimate
portrayal of loss her stellar
performance made it the obvious pick to
top our list
I have Newton toe of frog wing of bat
and tongue of dog adders fork and
blind-worms sting our bait Oh slime is
just the thing frag is salt like sailors
double flip the switch and let the
cauldron bubble
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
you